[Music]
it's no wonder netflix had to start
policing the set to make sure this film
got made with this many bloopers
at least you're comfortable
mirror mirror on the wall who's the
handsomest of them all
look at me you think i show this face to
everyone watch
[Music]
doing whatever you're doing
just
and we're back to approachably handsome
i'm gonna get you a matching vest to go
with those pants there we go
is it just us or are we thinking that
there might be real champagne in that
glass
i don't know what happened we were just
having a glass of champagne when all of
a sudden he
i don't know what happened we just had
some champagne and then he all looked
down
you know what i think it's funny booth
vin diesel's audition tape for cats it
exists
sorry what kind of account mr reynolds
anyhow i gave our friend inspector dos a
little jingle and i tipped her off about
that secure cayman island account you
stashed it in turns out and then
funneled into a secure list
then funneled into a secure lichtenstein
account and then funneled into a secure
lichtenstein trust
and then
just a second you know what you guys
just say
yes that is me eggs are apparently
hilarious to the rock no taken
so when were you gonna tell me about the
dirt egg i was never gonna tell you
about the third egg what were you gonna
tell me about the third egg well i
wasn't gonna tell you about this during
eggs
no we're going to get it right now watch
this
when were you going to tell me about the
third thing i wasn't going to tell you
about the third thing
i left my phone in there
you only have a finite amount of time to
save it are they acting or are they
being themselves the lines were
definitely blurred you went back in the
water because you thought i was dead i
left my phone in there so this whole
time you had a cell phone yes
i know he creates extraordinary logic
problems for the film
[Laughter]
you've come a long way
and i'm really proud of you thanks dad
oh that's perfect wow
you're the captain
how much time do we think gal gadot
spent doing charography
hello boys
oh my god hello boys oh my god
oh bummer i really wanted to do it the
easy way no one is harder on gal than
gal when she flops how do you know the
eggs there my mother was an egyptologist
i could read hieroglyphics before i
could read english how do you know the
agreement my mother
was an egyptologist
[Music]
just is she even in shock
need help with that egg ryan
five second rule
it's fine
[Music]
thank you
the rock is not a fan of fans good to
know
i'm a big fan
[Music]
yeah
there's four now how many takes are we
betting this line took
there's like three of these left on the
planet four
three of them left in the planet four
three-quarter inch steel reinforced
armor-plating bullet-resistant glass
solid
rubber tryout
just your partner the rock is a stellar
dancer but even he had his stumbles
careful now
[Music]
there we go
now i know
yes it's my father's watch
by day 39 of filming we're not too
surprised that the corpsing was constant
is that your father's watch is that your
father's watch
no
it's the watch from pulp fiction
it's the watch from publications
sorry
what accent is that exactly
i am innocent
okay last time
and
see
[Music]
[Music]
you